the beautiful thing about atheism is
just a refusal to believe in something
that's destructive or misguided or bad
for the world and some gods should be
rejected what I find so fascinating is
how many people I know or how many of my
friends who are atheists when we talk
about the God that they don't believe in
I don't believe in that God either and
some people who when you will ask them
so you're an atheist tell me about the
God you don't believe in and they tell
you about the image of God they were
handed perhaps growing up you think the
only healthy response to that image of
the divine would be atheism rejection of
that so religion has done horrible
things in the world a lot of violence
has been done in the name of God and the
atheist says I refuse to participate in
something that brings destruction and
chaos to the world now the really
interesting thing to me is what do you
do with wonder mystery and awe what do
you do with all of the fascinating
cosmology quantum physics what do you do
with all of the fascinating things where
we keep learning new things or human
consciousness who is the me that stands
in a observation of me what does it mean
to be a self
where is personhood located so I begin
with our great mysteries and the idea of
a divine being who is somehow guiding
the whole thing is takes a leap of
course it takes a leap but what I find
fascinating is none of us have slaves
and a generation ago we did so a couple
generations ago in America people did so
what is it about something that was a
standard cultural practice that we now
say that is wrong and unjust
or you think about women's rights or the
rights of our LGBT brothers and sisters
how many people do you know offer their
children as sacrifice none and yet that
was a normative practice in the ancient
world so what is it about the human
story we've been here what 13.8 billion
years what is it about the human story
that things that you people used to
consider normal standard cultural
practices we now look back on and say
how primitive how barbaric how wrong how
unjust how violent and so at the moment
we say that look how far we've come we
all go yeah but we also have a long way
to go we also have care for the
environment we also have all sorts of
things where we still have a long long
way to go so when I affirm both movement
from the past forward but the need to
keep going what is that arc like that
trajectory why do we all have a sense
that the whole thing is being pulled
forward not quickly enough we probably
would also agree where does that come
from where does an expanding universe in
which we keep moving forward in our
understanding of what it means for human
beings to live in proper relationship
with each other what do you call that
and that's the really interesting thing
I'm fine if somebody doesn't want to use
the word God because that word can be
all loaded down but you at least have to
acknowledge something's going on here
and when somebody says nothing's
happening here we're all just a
collection of our cells and synapses and
biology really really I think there's
something going on here